ladies and gentlemen welcome to
throwback thursday where we investigate
the con men
from old to learn lessons for our modern
era today we're taking a look
at the grand pappy of ponzi schemes
bernie
madoff he ran a 64.8 billion dollar
scheme before it was discovered in 2008
by himself he turned himself
in that's probably the first shocking
thing you need to know about bernie
madoff
is that his ponzi scheme was trucking
along until the financial market
collapsed in 2008
and everyone came looking for their
money now if you understand how a ponzi
scheme works where you're constantly
robbing peter to pay paul you're not
actually investing the money
you understand why this is a problem he
simply
didn't have it he didn't have those
magical one percent per month returns
that he had been promising people
for years that while the s p 500 was
going up and down with the market
they could trust him with their finances
and
why not after all he was the former
chairman of the nasdaq
he was a well-known market maker he was
known within wall street he was royalty
and so people just trusted him he didn't
go looking for investors they came to
him
his investment advisory was quite
frankly one of the most
elite clubs to be in you had to know
somebody who knew bernie
to get into his ponzi scheme so at first
hearing all these things you may be
envisioning
some brilliant genius conman who simply
outsmarted the feds outsmarted the
authorities who were just
just befuddled by how this could be
right up until the very end
but you'd be wrong see bernie didn't
evade suspicion in fact
almost his entire career he was being
investigated
by the sec or other regulatory agencies
so the real question is not how did a
bunch of people fall for a ponzi scheme
but how did we let it happen my theory
bernie made a big bluff
[Music]
when this is something that the public
really doesn't understand and you if you
read things in the newspaper and you see
somebody
you know violate a rule you say well you
know they're always doing this
but you it's impossible for you to go
under for a violation to go undetected
now obviously we know what he just said
is incredibly
ironic but it's also factually untrue he
literally got away
with his ponzi scheme for several
decades but this wasn't because bernie
madoff was some
genius fraudster in fact i want to share
with you
three examples from when bernie madoff
almost got caught he was
always it seems always almost getting
caught
to illustrate to you the absolute
incompetence
we were dealing with with the sec my
first example
the 1992 investigation according to a
report
into the sec's failure to catch madoff
in june of 1992
several customers of an investment firm
known as avelino
and bynes approached the sec conveying
concerns about investments they had made
the sec was provided with several
documents that
indicated that they were offering a
hundred percent safe
investments now what did the sec suspect
that this company was doing
when they heard about high and extremely
consistent rates of return well they
suspected them of operating
a ponzi scheme but later realized that
madoff bernie madoff had taken complete
control
over their customers now what does the
sec do
they suspect this company this
investment company that's selling these
high consistent returns
of running a ponzi scheme they find out
that madoff
manages all their funds so what do they
do
well they shut down this company which
they suspect of being a ponzi scheme but
do they investigate madoff for being
upon this game
no in fact in a wall street journal
article from 1992
this is written about how basically
there was a mystery investor it says
the mystery broker turned out to be none
other than bernard
madoff a highly successful and
controversial figure on wall street
in a stroke of what could be described
as unfortunate irony
it says in the article regulators feared
it might all just be a huge scam this is
16 years before the ponzi falls apart we
went into it thinking it could be a
major catastrophe
says richard walker the sec's new york
regional administrator
really you thought you thought it could
be a scam
no no it was a scam you just didn't look
so that's exhibit one of the sec's
enormous incompetence
but now i want to draw you to the
refrigerator
this is much later in the fraud so
apparently kpmg
was looking for a document that they had
not known was going to be asked for
so this guy testifies now i have a big
problem these guys are looking for
non-existent records
right because they're not a real trading
company normally you could provide this
but they don't actually trade
uh their ponzi scheme and so this is how
like half hazard
the madoff organization was at this
point he calls downstairs to two of the
guys down there and says hey
bring me up such and such report i need
it in 10 minutes
knowing that this report it doesn't
exist
so the guys downstairs they have to make
it up
literally from scratch and they know
that oh it's going to be hot
you know this is supposed to be a
well-worn report it's good but it's
going to be hot it's
supposed to be from years ago it doesn't
exist so they put it in the refrigerator
to cool it down
because the guys are right upstairs they
need to bring it up and then
they toss it around like quote a
medicine ball
picture that these guys tossing around a
newly created fraudulent document like a
medicine ball so it would
seem like it's worn and they bring it
upstairs and present it
and nobody is the wiser now
is that the story of some brilliant
you know fraudster no that's a guy who
can barely get it together that's an
organization that is on the brink of
falling apart
and yet once again they live to fight
another day
up till now nobody's really seriously
looked into the bernie madoff fraud
possibility until one man named harry
markopoulos
appears on the scene according to him he
looked at bernie madoff's books
and in five minutes he knew the whole
thing was a fraud in four hours
a ponzi scheme and harry said
this is a fraud and then four hours
later he says this is a ponzi scheme
so what do you do if you're harry
markopoulos and you realize that one of
the largest hedge fund managers on wall
street is actually a fraudster
well you take it to the sec of course
and they ignored him why did they ignore
him you asked
that's a great question see obviously
the oig
investigated the sec everyone's
investigating you know themselves
investigating did no wrong did wrong
and the reason they didn't take harry
markopoulos claim seriously is because
how could bernie madoff be a ponzi
scheme if he was trading in europe
that's why they dismissed harry
markopoulos he showed them
mathematically that it was impossible to
do what bernie madoff was doing
and they said mr markopoulos did not
know that the trades were done in europe
so they dismissed him now did bernie
madoff trade in europe
apparently as the story goes madoff had
his office set up in such a way
that whenever investigators asked to see
evidence of
this trading one trader would sit at the
desk showing
that they're trading with europe while
the guy down the hall
would execute the european side of the
trade
so they literally had it set up in such
a way that two guys are in the same
building just
sweating i imagine hoping that these
regulators
will simply go away so the sec sees that
and goes
oh i guess i guess that's legit
and at that point you have to wonder
what are they going to find well
um nothing time after time
the sec bungles the case they just slips
out of their hands at one point
they they have this thing where they're
gonna seek records from something called
the depository trust company
which is an independent third party and
they ask madoff for his account number
whatever he gives it to them
and he says at that point monday morning
they'll call the dtc and it'll be over
basically he goes my
my time is up he knew it except that
never happened
why because they never called the place
to verify
the trades literally at every corner
the sec is just falling over themselves
to miss the largest ponzi scheme in
human
history and the question is again
how i have a few answers at my disposal
here
and i'm going to give you my own answer
as well one is what harry markopoulos
believed
he said i believe that the one
overarching deficiency is that the sec
is a group of 3 500 chickens tasks to
track down
and catch foxes which are way faster
stronger
and smarter than they are the sec itself
says that they think
that the teams assembled to investigate
madoff were quote
inexperienced and there was insufficient
planning for the examinations
now those are good theories harry
markopoulos also says that he thinks
that the sec has too big of a
conflict of interest with wall street
and with madoff and that's maybe one of
the reasons why
and i think i think that's possible but
i think there's something else going on
here too
see with someone like bernie madoff
you have an emperor has no clothes
problem where someone is so
powerful someone is so experienced and
well known within their industry
that it becomes almost unfathomable that
they will be caught
and i think that bernie's big bluff was
not
to go ahead and make the most
sophisticated financial con in human
history
it was that i think he knew that he'd be
dressed the part
he looked the part and played the part
well enough
nobody would bother looking after all
how could you fathom that the guy who's
saying
this when this is something that the
public really doesn't understand and you
if you read things in the newspaper and
you see somebody you know violate a rule
you say well you know they're always
doing this
but you it's impossible for you to go
under for a violation to go undetected
how could that be the guy running the
biggest ponzi scheme in human history
can't be him he's that nice well-spoken
guy
who you know uncle bernie he wouldn't do
he would do no harm
i think it was the sheer audacity of
what he did
that led so many people to simply sweep
it under the rug to not
look too carefully the people who
suspected him they even suspected him of
a different crime entirely
they thought maybe he was front-running
trades right which is illegal but
the profits are real they thought maybe
he's committing a little bit of fraud
but not that much fraud
nobody thought about a ponzi scheme
because quite simply
it was outside the realm of possibility
that is what made bernie's bluff so
effective
so nobody looked into it nobody except
someone looking at the numbers harry
markopoulos
was one of the few people to not only
suspect bernie madoff
but also accuse him of running a ponzi
scheme before it all collapsed in 2008
and i think the lesson we can learn from
this is to not simply look at the
outside
appearance of somebody just because they
have a lambo just because they have a
suit just because they have quote
millions of dollars
or are even if they are respected by
their peers
or they appear to have connections this
does not preclude them from
all sorts of insane behavior that we
can't explain later on
i mean it's all well and good to say
that someone's a psychopath after the
fact
but nobody was accusing bernie of being
a psychopath before the fact nobody knew
it
and the only way you could have known at
the time that bernie
was actually committing the fraud that
he was was not giving him
the benefit of the doubt and that is one
of the craziest things to swallow
because once you realize the most
well-dressed well-adjusted
wealthy people in the world can be
psychopaths
and you don't even know
that's that's a scary thought so guys
i'd like to
end this video on an upside
justice was served in the end the 3 500
chickens harry markopoulos talked about
eventually came home to roost but if
you're out there
and you want to be safe don't invest in
something you don't believe in
bernie's saying was just trust me just
trust me
just trust me with your money right you
don't have to understand it no you do
have to understand it
and if you're an investor today it's all
the more important just remember
bernie's big bluff doesn't work if you
call him thanks for watching
and i'll see you next time
[Music]